so we are joined today by a legend
uh at least as far as i am concerned and
my family is concerned
super excited to meet today's guest
david pogue
of so many different outlets and uh i
want to ask you first david
if a if a hyper-intelligent alien wakes
you up in the middle of the night
and says what are you who are you how do
you define yourself you do so many
things from writing to tv
to to activism to uh to just real
intellectualism
how do you define yourself to yourself
i mean i think the one thing everything
i do has in common is
i'm a science and tech explainer so i
it's it's buried over the years it was
the new york times for 13 years it was
it's been cbs news sunday morning since
2002
uh it's books it's talks it's podcasts
with
esteemed physicists uh so but it's all
you know communicating science and tech
to lay people yeah and you do a
phenomenal job
i want to talk to you later about issues
of communication
because you know they all joke about
scientists and engineers as i'm sure
you've heard how do you know a scientist
or engineer is outgoing
he looks at your shoes when he talks to
you
that's my favorite joke i tell that
everywhere i go i know i got to get a
new one if
you ever come up with a new one promise
you'll you'll give me a a
you know credit or at least i can have
the rights to buy them from you
anyway david uh today you're joining the
into the impossible podcast
uh because of your marvelous new book
how to prepare for climate change
and i'm going to put a whole bunch of
bonus materials and links and so forth
i first want to express my gratitude uh
to leo laporte
so i've listened to leo longer than i've
listened to you and you guys were once
together a long time ago and actually
just this year when the book came out
you were on this show
and i was listening to it with my son
who is you know more blown away
uh by your presence than almost anyone
except for neil degrasse tyson
who is your opening act as we were
discussing later yeah earlier rather
um so we were listening and i was like
david i wonder if i could get david you
know there's got to be some way i've had
nine nobel prize winners on the show can
i get david pogue
uh and then i just like i reached out
and somehow you said yes and then
a fit of irrationality you said yes but
i want to thank you for doing that
because it exposed me
gave me a chance to go back and look
over all these wonderful things
and express gratitude to leo laporte i
hope someday to meet him maybe host him
on the podcast
but he hosts that the tech guy and mac
break weekly which is what you were
appearing
but anyway david this book is really
phenomenal and
it's um it's unique i'm having uh dr
lawrence krauss
on the podcast in the coming months to
talk about his new book
the physics of climate change i've got
that somewhere around here he's
just like me and and he'll bring a
different perspective um
and rebut everything you and i too no
i'm just kidding because your book is
not about physics
it is like your other books you give
these delicious
wonderful ticks and trips and trips and
traps and
hacks i think of you as a hacker and i
mean that in the best possible way
is that what animates you solving these
problems both on how to do the missing
manual for iphones that they don't give
you
all the way up to how to survive and
thrive in the era that's
certainly coming climate change is that
how you think of yourself as a tinkerer
and hacker like me
yeah i think so i think um i mean you're
absolutely right that as a how-to
author that's been a through line of my
entire career so
i started my writing career writing
dummies books
i wrote max for dummies and opera for
dummies classical music for dummies
magic for dummies
and so early early on in my 20s i
learned
to explain stuff simply and
winnow out that which was necessary and
that which was marketing
overload in terms of features so yeah so
i've always been a how-to author
this this book actually wasn't my idea
i'll i'll freely admit it i
pitched an entirely different book to
simon
and their their chief non-fiction
priscilla payton said
you know yeah yeah we we like that we'll
we'll do that book eventually but
first we've been kicking around this
idea and we think you're the guy
and she says let me lay this on you how
to prepare
for climate change and like from the
moment she said that
i thought this is the intertwining
of the two threads of my life a how-to
author
and a science explainer right that the
two sides are
could come together in this and i
remember saying could be like
where to live and how to ensure and how
to invest and what to grow
how to talk to your children and these
became the chapters
and her title became the title like
nothing changed
from that moment in early 2019
well i think of it as a sort of a bible
a self-help book
everything rolled into one i'll note it
is longer than the old testament which
is kind of cool
and it's certainly more uh dramatic
although it's hard to compete with god
except in the flooding chapters where
you will rival god of course
uh and so i i found this book very
um very well unique for lack of a better
word because you
you don't start with the premise of you
know is it happening
you know what what you know what is
actually the facts and the physics as
lawrence you know will presumably
discuss with me
when he comes on but uh but rather it is
happening and like any other thing
we in science we talk about or
engineering rather we talk about
risk matrices what is the probability of
a given risk what is the financial
impact or human impact
but um you know i always point out when
none of us and no matter how brilliant
we were had
global pandemic will strike and uh you
know in our risk registers we're
building our telescope
so i ask you you know in this book it's
it's a fact we talk about things that
aren't that aren't probabilities anymore
they're facts the climate is
changing humans play some role in it and
so you start with that premise
and why was that important as just a
given as a starting point to start from
that uh from that assumption
wow what an incredible observation right
really that
that was literally what kept me awake at
night is that
at the time in 2019 climate change was
so
controversial more controversial than it
is today and
i knew two things i knew number one i
was going to be beaten up
no matter what i did um and number two
um i didn't i i'm not i'm thin skinned i
don't like that so
my whole thing was how can i write a
book
that nobody can object to now when we
say climate change denier
i think that meaning has changed i think
we used to think of a denier as someone
who says
the climate isn't changing and i think
the number of people
in that category are vanishingly small
today i think you'd be hard-pressed to
get someone to say
the weather is this the seasons are the
same as they were in the 80s
i mean it's look at the news look at out
your window
um today i think a climate denier is
more likely to be somebody who says well
yeah
the the seasons and the weather are
changing but it's a natural cycle
the earth has always had this it's not
man-made
but the the beauty for me as the author
of this book is
i don't care i don't care if you think
it's natural or not
you still need to prepare you know it's
still doing a number
on your family and your house and your
work and your life and your health
so you still need to prepare either way
so
the the way so that was one way that
this terror
of being attacked manifested itself is
starting from the stance that look let's
all agree something's going on
that you're in danger how do you fix it
and
the second thing was you can't tell by
reading it
but there are so many footnotes
in this book that the editor suggested
no no we will because david
i have a 97 page supplemental file that
i'm putting in the youtube description
i love it it's scholarly david it is
extremely scholarly i'd like to invite
you to get your phd with me
based on the scholarship it's rigorous
it is in all seriousness this is
extremely rigorous i was going to bring
that up
yeah she there were so many i read each
and every one by the way i read each and
every one
you followed like a good academic i'm
i'm looking for my name to be cited so
for some reason that you misspelled
keeling and you started cheating
yeah there there were the the text was
so thick with little superscript numbers
that my editor said like no one can read
this let's rip them all out and make
them all in a giant endnotes document
and that's the 97 page addendum that
you're talking about
so the book is much cleaner to read but
i can assure you there's not a
phrase in there that's not backed up by
research
well what's so interesting about this
book like all your books
it's it's practical and it's amazing
like how could it be practical
and i thought about reading as i'm
reading it i like to be a little
philosophical but i was thinking of
pascal
blaise pascal and his famous wager and
the wager is
revolves around the existence of a deity
and he basically says makes the case
that
even if you don't believe in god you
should act as if god exists now we're
not going to get into god's existence
because the penalty in other words the
risk penalty times the probability
is infinite you know eternal damnation
you know if you're wrong and god does
exist and you act as if he doesn't exist
so uh but but in this book you can act
this the way that this book
informs you to act and it doesn't matter
it's true whether you believe it or not
and and in that sense i found as mark
twain said
your books uh don't don't maybe maybe
they don't echo
or repeat but they rhyme in that i was
reading a rereading again
your book about uh life hacks and you
know basically
it's a book where you talk about like as
you're driving down the freeway
if the exit sign has an exit number on
the right-hand side of the sign that
means the exit will be on the right and
here in southern california it's like
sometimes there are some freeways here
david i don't know if you remember from
your time
that you spent in california there are
some freeways that go north south east
and west in l.a but we're not going to
talk about la uh but but anyway
this book is as practical as that
because you're giving examples
insurance investing and i thought it
very very
beautiful that you open up a psychology
and i wonder if you could talk a little
bit about that what
what and once you decided to write this
book and make this book up
how did psychology come to be present in
it and why did you lead off with it
i think uh my interest in climate change
came from my feelings about climate
change so i i like
many people many you know intellectual
coastal people uh had
you know melancholia climate melancholy
or eco despair as they call it
and you know the world that we've always
known
is changing beneath our feet it's
terrifying
uh we have you know i have children i'm
hoping for grandchildren you know so
um it occurs to me that the first way to
prepare for climate change
is somehow accepting it it's somehow
coming to terms with it to help yourself
and uh the above mentioned editor
priscilla payton hilariously
after reading the manuscript said i
think you've written the first
uplifting book about climate change and
what you meant by that is that an
uplifting 12-step
program yeah that's great that's right
in in
any realm of depression uh
that it's not just that you feel like
your situation sucks it's that you feel
like your situation sucks
and you're helpless to change it that's
the key
they did a cool study in a prison where
mental health problems are rampant
uh where they allowed inmates one each
week to arrange the chairs
for the group movie night or the group
events
and just that tiny bit of control over
the environment
gave people a boost that made them sleep
better at night so
that's that's kind of the idea here
taking any of the preparation steps in
this book
will make you feel better about life
because you've taken
some steps to control your situation um
and so really haunting the entire book
is this notion of psychology and feeling
better
so i did think like we should really
start off with calling a spade a spade
you're reading this book because you're
worried
yeah yeah and in that sense having
agency
i found that uh to be uplifting as you
say
and so i i wanted to you know commend
you on that uh kind of counterintuitive
way to start off a book about
you know which necessarily at its root
is a book about physics and you know the
impact of things downstream
from a physical process which is you
know as lawrence points out in his book
if you took all the carbon
and all the carbon dioxide in our
atmosphere and condensed it magically
and made it into like
um you know kind of a layer that coated
the planet it would coat the entire
planet
one millimeter thick now imagine like a
shell like carbon fiber shell
surrounding the earth it's visceral and
in this case you know but it's
the way that the way that we talk about
climate change it's in the future and
yeah it's bad for people in the future
but i always say like
maybe i'll ask you this david because
you know know that i love you what's the
name of your uh
paternal great great great
what's the first name of my paternal
great great great grandfather well
five generations back i mean his last
name was presumably pogue
that's right yeah but i made it easy but
the first name
yeah no idea you don't know so i i say
well that
would be fools to think that doesn't
apply to us so in other words your great
great great great grandson or
daughter five generations probably won't
know about you
so you know sometimes i hear the
argument who cares about that guy or
that girl
like we should live for today how do you
answer people that make those kinds of
objections
i mean that's just a moral conscience
issue that's just
you know that the central thing about
caring for others
even people we don't know i mean that it
has nothing to do with them being my
descendants
i care for people i don't know no matter
who they are
yes yeah and in the sense that we
you know we have uh you know evidence we
have reason we have
the faculty of rational thought you know
being able to take action i have heard
from some of your previous uh podcasts
that i've listened to
people criticizing you and saying oh
you're thinking rather venally you know
you're saying how could you invest
how can you decide where to move and and
isn't that part of your privilege and
and that you have agency
in all these dimensions and maybe
everyone else doesn't how do you answer
critics like that
yeah that's a that's another thing that
haunted this whole book um
climate change as we all know
disproportionately affects poor
people communities of color always has
for some really nasty reasons having to
do with you know redlining and policy
early on
this is not supposed to be a book on how
to spend
money to come out ahead when the climate
chips are down
so the there is a chapter on where to
live where to move
um but it begins with an acknowledgement
that not everybody can move
of any income level you have a social
circle you have a job
but it takes off from the premise that
40 million americans a year
do move they get out of school they
gotta get out of military they get
married they get divorced they get a new
job
and so increasingly where to move
is becoming one of the decision factors
especially by the way after the pandemic
when we realize
oh my god i don't have to go into an
office every day to do my job
so you can now choose more or less where
to be to do your remote work
so that's on the where to move thing and
on the on the investment thing
i i really stressed about that until i
started interviewing
investors um by the way i'm not an
expert
on any of the topics in this book i'm
not an investment guy or an insurance
guy or a psychology guy
it's all based on expert interviews uh
with
fantastic people um and what the
insurance people told me was yeah
investing is about making money if you
have money to invest but when you're
investing
in companies that will make you money
through clean energy
you're doing something good for
everybody you're supporting
mitigation as well as adapting and
making
making a profit from the adaptation so i
recognize that not every american is
capable of making investments
but if those who do make investments
that support green technologies
um then the world is better for
everybody
and and i guess the last piece of that
answer those are the two
smoking guns on the is this an elite
book question
all the other chapters how to garden how
to prepare a go bag how to survive a
hurricane
all of those are things that are free to
everybody
and also the impact of these things and
by the way the
the footnotes the 97 pages in all
seriousness they contain
tremendous numbers of resources uh for
free websites free activities you know
plotters modelers
um computers all the way down to like
basically self-help you know free
self-help organizations where you can go
or not self-help group help and i think
it's
i think it's uh fascinating and it's
it's a wonderful service david in all
in all uh honesty i want to turn to you
know something that
i by the way i'm i am um i'm really
pretty vehemently opposed to the term
denier as a jewish person
i find that that term is so loaded it's
so freighted that it's almost impossible
to have a conversation it's like calling
somebody a racist like yeah once you use
that racist term
as i was by uh almost was by neil
degrasse tyson later earlier this week
but that was in in uh and you know maybe
maybe it was well deserved i don't know
uh but we had a wonderful conversation
i'm just kidding
uh but but the um but that term is is a
loaded one so
it's it's hard to have a conversation
when somebody accuses you of so
but but one thing the people that uh not
that don't object that don't deny that
it's happening as you say
uh they're very few people that actually
will say that but they'll say that um
you know requiring the exact termination
of the phenomena that led to the problem
that we're in
is short-sighted and in fact in some
ways it's against the scientific method
and one of my favorite ways to
to kind of play that devil's advocate
maybe literally maybe figuratively
is ask you about something which i know
you're an expert in but but maybe i'll
describe anyway
the great horse manure crisis of 1894
are you familiar with that
okay so back in 1994
in the times of london a writer
estimated that in 50 years
every street in london would be buried
under nine feet of manure
and it actually took an exact same
attack in wall street in lower manhattan
as well they were claiming that the
stock market was going through these
awful you know kind of uh gyrations
because
traders couldn't get to work uh and and
then actually they'd come in they get
really tremendous illnesses the water
was polluted
um and of course the way that we solve
that is not with horse diapers or you
know getting
you know horse to uh to you know use a
toilet or something like that
it was we invented the automobile or you
know the automobiles rise came up
so what do you say to those that say by
saying that we just curtail everything
we're actually diminishing the power of
human ingenuity
to innovate our way out of this problem
or and perhaps go beyond it in other
words the way that the automobile
radically improved life not just made
the horse manure problem better
solving that but actually improved our
life in innumerable ways
who's to say that you know innovation
can't solve this problem as well
i mean it will let's hope it will
there's
right now we're pulling every string
we've got we are pursuing
every avenue in fact the last chapter of
my book is called where to find hope
and it was for people who have spent the
last four years of presidential
administration
seeing the words climate change wiped
from federal websites and pulling out of
the paris agreement and so on
it turns out that no matter what the
federal government has been doing for
the last few years
an awful lot of people institutions and
even 24
states are still
moving full speed ahead to solve the
problem there is
all kinds of innovation going on
another related question is is it right
to write a book about adaptation
which this book is about will that cause
people
to lose their zeal to stop polluting in
the first place
yeah is it is it throwing in the towel
and saying oh okay
let's just cope with what we've got
instead of trying to fix the problem
no no one's saying that we're all saying
we have to do
everything we're way behind we're 40
years behind getting started
we have to try everything so there are
some amazing
new technologies at work i mean those um
those carbon removal plants that that
suck carbon dioxide back out of the
ground
out of the air and pump it into the
ground or even some of them are even
selling it
to carbonated beverage companies they
need carbon dioxide
that's a big problem even the the ipcc
the intergovernmental
panel on climate change confesses that
we're not going to get there
unless those machines are part of the
equation
so yeah we need to innovate we need to
mitigate we need to adapt
we need to do everything simultaneously
and and the other i mean
the other problem with with criticizing
dismantling the fossil fuel thing
is that it doesn't hurt us to do so in
other words
solar and wind power are already less
expensive
than most other kinds of power and in
most parts of the country um
and it's millions of new jobs it's a
whole new infrastructure to build
why wouldn't we want it why wouldn't we
want to make this change
as long as it helps everybody it gets
less bad stuff that we're breathing
it stops climate change um it doesn't
yeah and and and of course reusable
clean energy like wind and solar
will be with us till the end of the
planet sucking oil out of the ground
won't that's got a finite end to it
yeah that's one thing that charles
keeling's son who's a professor here at
scripps
institution of oceanography um they
you know he makes the point there's a
finite amount of carbon on the earth
it's not like there's an infinite amount
and so he predicts
i think there's a peak just you know if
you were to use some efficiency factor
times the total storehouse of carbon in
the planet
you know there weren't infinite numbers
of dinosaurs let's put it that way so
uh so eventually we'd run out of carbon
and then you know the problem solved
that question is you know do we reach
some tipping point
the last you know kind of non-specific
to this book but kind of
uh general to global warming or climate
change
is this notion that you know we already
have a solution
that actually could be advocated for on
behalf
of by readers of your book uh or and
we're talking about how to prepare for
climate change
uh and and that is nuclear power and and
in fact nuclear power has this awful
stigma
but actually the coal that replaced the
nuclear power plants in in europe
after the fukushima disaster you know
contributed some way much more to human
suffering and human ill
illness than the uh than radioactivity
ever did not to minimize the tragedies
et cetera but um but nuclear power we
know is as a tremendous capability
um to power all electrical needs and yet
we
in here in southern california just
deactivated one reactor san onofre
not too long ago and uh there aren't
plans to build any new ones here at
least in california
uh what do you make about nuclear as as
a as a not not
obviously from the physics perspective
but for advocacy you know you you
actually go through about 10 15 pages of
really practical
advice coming down to admitting that
some of the times the best way to get
your congress
you know critter's attention is uh
through a donation
you're not you're actually afraid to say
that which i love
that you do you're a realist you're a
pragmatist but anyway getting back to
the advocacy
why would you know that doesn't play as
big a role in this book and i'm curious
is there a reason for that
um yeah i think i think because
um well but there is some
there's a chapter on advocacy um and i
think
it that most the results of advocacy is
again mitigation
i i gotta tell you you think this book
is long at 620 pages
it used to be longer when i turned this
when i turned this book in it was a
thousand pages long
and my editor was just like oh no
oh no oh no we can't we can't do this
and she suggested that i draw a line
between adaptation which the book is
supposed to be about
and all the mitigation stuff there were
all there's all this stuff on how to
reduce your carbon footprint
we cut that out we made that an online
appendix got 300 pages off the book
um so i think that's probably the reason
there's not more in it about advocacy
that
that and the fact that it's not a
political issue to me
it's yeah it's a humanity survival issue
and i really didn't want to get all
messed up i think that the word trump
doesn't even appear in the book
even though i was writing it during that
period because like why
lose people through some political
reference
when i had them with me up until then
and um and on the on the nuclear stuff
um
you know i love and you probably i'm
stomping on your turf here you probably
know way more about this than i do but
what i've learned is that uranium
powers our nuclear plants today because
when nuclear power was getting started
decades ago the government
wanted something that could also be
weaponized
they used that element to develop
nuclear power because it could also be
made into bombs
but there are other elements that can't
be used for bombs
that don't have the meltdown potential
that could still be nuclear power
there's thorium nuclear that that's been
demonstrated in in five or six countries
um bill gates is is heavily invested in
this thing traveling wave nuclear
um which is a different isotope of
uranium and can even be
derived from the fuel rise that we're
throwing away
from our current plants um so nuclear is
not out of the question at all
even if you're afraid of uranium power
plants
yeah did i get absolutely correct yeah
thorium is an amazing
yes absolutely yeah thorium is one of
the most promising
alternatives to uranium which has a much
lower half-life and
and uh much more uh it cannot be
weaponized as you say
as as uranium plutonium can be um that's
certainly true and and and there may
have been also other governmental
reasons that you know this is in the
race to defeat uh you know an enemy
during war and now we're
you know we don't have those time
pressures you'd think that we'd be
acting more
you know kind of cogently uh but but i
think it has this terrible you know just
like the search for aliens
you know it's kind of um uh damaged by
the
you know prosthetic foreheads that
appear in every sci-fi movie
you know the the act you know the
association of you know
of you know fusion or fission power with
uranium with bombs with destroying the
planet
is um is of course unfortunate but uh
you know maybe is a guilt by association
that's unnecessary
i love the fact that you you know you
dig in literally pun intended
into things like gardening because all
these things that you talk about
uh david this is actually a stealth
science book
and i know you are a science technology
reporter but this you know i was like
thinking with my kids you know it's just
terrible to admit but i'll admit it to
you because we're friends we go way back
to the top of the hour
but um i was planting some seeds after i
started reading this book as i do every
year
and uh i i was thinking it actually
allows you to learn tremendous amounts
of things from statistics
there's something called pareto
principle which is that eighty percent
of results come from twenty percent of
your crops
or you know in your business you know uh
eighty percent of the problems come from
twenty percent of your fellow reporters
uh in the newsroom um and then there's
uh and so
you actually see eighty percent of your
seeds are produ are you know that
blossom come from just 20
and i actually observed that exact
phenomena i tweeted about this
uh and i'm like damn you pareto why do
you have to be so accurate
but then one of my kids i got a bunch of
kids and uh and 20
of them are evil no they're not evil
they're lovely but uh 20
of them will come up and uh they'll
destroy like one of these saplings these
beautiful saplings that like
you know won't grow in just dirt like we
can't just go to the you know go to the
store and get some silica
and some carbon mix them together with
some phosphorus it won't grow it needs
microbes
and so i'm teaching about microbes and
then you know so it's biology and i'm a
physicist what do i know about biology
right
uh spherical cows are the most closely
related things to biology that i get it
too
and then one of my kids like takes the
whole thing of seeds and like falls on
the ground
and i swear it was like someone took a
sledgehammer to my car
it was just like i was like gonna yell
at him and yeah he's like three years
old almost
um but but i realize how close you get
to these things like you know
better almost like a goldfish or
something you know it's it becomes like
part of you and then you learn about it
through getting your hands literally
dirty and so again
this is a this is a science book it's a
book for children even though you talk
about you know thinking about the
children and protecting children later
on
so what was was that kind of you know
one of the goals is like the
part of coping and acceptance is taking
action
and i and i feel like that was a very
strong theme in this book
yeah and and the uh and not only that
but this is a book about
personal adaptation in other words yes i
this all came this whole mitigation
adaptation thing came from
this um this quote by obama's senior
science advisor
he said when it comes to climate change
there's mitigation there's adaptation
and there's suffering and how much
suffering we're going to do depends on
how much of the first suit we're going
to do this is john holdren
and the thing is if you look on amazon
right now
there's something like 300 or 400 books
about climate change mitigation and
there were zero books about the second
half of his equation
there were no books about adaptation
none that's what i wrote
i wrote the only one and so but
adaptation isn't a new thing
to businesses and governments and
industry i mean
that's why cities build sea walls that's
adaptation
that's why monsanto is developing
drought resistant seeds
that's adaptation so the question is
what things
can an individual do what can families
do
and so that that's where this peculiar
set of chapters came from you can set up
a garden even if you live in an
apartment you can do gardening
you can check over your insurance and
realize
oh my gosh nobody's home insurance
covers
flooding nobody's and flooding is a big
big deal
there's some so many great statistics in
the book as you have
shrewdly observed but um one of my
favorite
is that seven of the 10 most flooded
states
in the u.s are not on the coasts
they're inland states that are flooding
from things like
the ground getting baked by drought and
then a heavy rain
can't soak in so it floods or dams
breaking or rivers overflowing their
banks
and stuff like that so anyway so that's
where this peculiar set of chapters came
from
the number of things an individual can
do isn't
infinite and i just wanted to make sure
i covered everything you could do
and as a uh as a graduate of case
western reserve university
in beautiful cleveland ohio as i am a
former spartan
i grew up like you from cleveland yes i
i know that
um i also point out that even though you
talk about something which
in another interview which shall be
named nameless
um you know you know could be construed
as elitism
actually it's kind of the reverse
because you say you know moving to
cleveland
your dollar stretches two times as far
as it does here in sandy maybe four
times as far as it does here in san
diego or new york city
and actually is that not a dividend to a
parent who says look the quality of life
is better
i love cleveland ohio you know it's it's
and it's certainly
you know my main objection 1993 when i
graduated was the winters
you know are are so harsh and and it's a
good thing that they only last from
you know september 30th to may 30th it
actually snowed on my graduation day
in 1993. and i don't think it's done
that recently right
no um the the so yeah so you're talking
about the chapter about where to
consider
moving and you know the basic rule is
you want to move north far enough to
avoid
the hurricanes and the heat you know
west far enough to avoid the hurricanes
on the east coast and the ticks of the
mosquitoes
east far enough to avoid the droughts
and the wildfires
and as you say that leaves you with the
great lakes area
and all these grand old cities that used
to be far more populous
you know cleveland duluth cincinnati
madison syracuse
that people fled when industry went away
now they're poised to be climate havens
and yeah that for for cleveland that
figure is
a dollar in new york city buys you 2.71
cents of
worth of stuff in cleveland is
incredible how much house you can buy in
cleveland
it is but the the 14th culture
and the arts exactly it's not just about
climate havens right you
the 14 cities i picked in the book to
look at are ones that
also have great quality of life great
people great workforce diversity
room to grow education hospitals
if if you want anything in the climate
change era you want access to good
health care
um airports and so on so uh
i was very happy to and i actually i
actually did a story for
cbs sunday morning on this topic what's
the best climate haven city in
america and actually visited madison
madison wisconsin
and you know that's the same argument
like
isn't that really cold um
it's five degrees warmer than it was in
the 80s
and it's expected to get another 11
degrees warmer
in the winters by 2050. so those
cold cold winters of those great lake
cities yeah
but they're getting warmer and that's
why you want to move there now
and as you point out so i spent right
after case western i went to university
of uh wisconsin at madison no so you're
like you're following me around yeah uh
but uh
that was i was yeah exactly so there um
and there you point out which i always
love this little treat first of all
uh the best farmers market in the world
every saturday uh morning
on the capitol and you could always see
the capital because as you point out the
architecture
what does it do they have they have
zoning rules you're not allowed to build
anything
not just taller than the capitol
building but that would block your view
of the capitol building
so it'll never become a concrete jungle
uh david next i want to introduce our
audience who has never heard this term
on the into the impossible podcast
reminder we're talking with david pogue
uh one of my favorite authors of all
time i can't believe he's on the show
he's
he's uh kind of hanging out with
somebody like me but i've listened to
him for years
uh decades probably closer to to reality
sunday morning cbs we watch him all the
time and uh it's funny for me david to
have a second generation of my family
and involved in the in the pogue worship
that we do so have
clearly have excellent taste someday
i'll get a finger puppet made of you
like we did with galileo galilei
but that that that will be after maybe
your next your next book comes out
um i want to talk now about uh a term
that we've never used this is a
neologism as they used to say at the new
york times where you
used to used to be regular and that is
uh at least for this
audience tio tawaki tioki can you
explain what that
is and how one should deal with that in
the coming years
and a practical way as you describe and
how to prepare for climate change
yeah that's one of these survivalist
acronyms it stands for
the end of the world as we know it and
they have all these great ones you know
there's uh shtf which is when the
hits the fan and uh it all refers to
bug out bag yeah that's right when the
chips are really down and
disaster hits and what's really curious
is that
the survivalists you know some of whom
are whack jobs
but all of them have this premise that
the world is going to
be in bad shape and they're going to be
sitting pretty
when the rest of us are fumbling for a
bottle of water at the grocery store
um they they loved the whole pandemic
thing they love hurricanes they love
wildfires
they are not making runs to the grocery
store they do not worry about where
they're going to get gasoline for their
generators
they've already got it they have studied
how to ride out
this kind of disruption and believe it
or not
some of that leaks into this book leaks
into this concept
of personal preparation obviously i'm
not talking about building an
underground bunker with food for six
months
but i do think it's safe no matter where
you live
to have two weeks of storable groceries
you know beans and canned stuff
in case you are supposed to block down
in your house for a while
as just happened in 2020 right
um these survivalists were like ha ha
pandemic see you suckers um
while the rest of us were panicking
about leaving our homes
so there's all kinds of reasons you
might want to
have simple preparations like a
storehouse of food
like some water in the basement um like
a go bag
i helped my my youngest kid make a go
bag for his
his boy scout merit badge and you know
what it was fun
you know it was a scavenger hunt we ran
around a go bag is
something you keep a backpack you keep
in the front closet
for when you are told by authorities to
evacuate
and it's got everything you need to last
for a couple days outside your home it's
got
snacks and water purification pills
first aid kit flashlight
a mirror stuff like that and uh i mean
to to people in california as you must
know brian
this is not a new concept a lot of
californians already have them
um increasingly there's no place in
america
where having a go bag isn't useful i
mean i live in connecticut
and you would think well what on earth
is the problem with connecticut i'll
tell you
hurricane sandy was a problem in
connecticut
we lost power for six days it was
cold we had no heat no electricity no
internet
no tv nothing i had three little kids
and yeah sure you spend the first
afternoon playing cards by candlelight
and
talking about how lucky we are to live
in the modern era
you know what by that night you're
losing your gourd
dad what can we do so it's it doesn't
let him
i want a pizza yeah six days was
yeah but again that's a an activity
another example of kind of the
you know homesteading education of the
bygone era that you can engage in with
this uh
really phenomenal book how to prepare
for climate change i have it in kindle
and and other formats and audio uh as
well we can listen to it
but i want to uh also mention that one
of my sons when hearing about this he
said
um david needs some merch he needs some
merch so i was thinking about some pogue
brand
pogbrand bug out bags what do you think
can i get a little kickback from my
one of my older sons absolutely
for sure uh so speaking of kids before
we close out the show with the questions
i ask
all my guests who are so illustrious uh
just like you and honor me
by coming on the end of the impossible
podcast relating to kids
the one part of the book i found kind of
a downer uh was
uh but only because it's reality uh is
that people are having fewer and fewer
children i think last year was
one of the fewest on record both in the
us and and um
in europe and you know part of that is
because of climate anxiety and some
obviously covid was you know some people
are saying we're going to have a boom in
weddings and
i said to my wife or divorces you know
like
it just depends on you know what side
you want to focus on but um
but this this thing and then and then
you bring up all these statistics and
the footnotes again let's say
you know only kids are a lot more likely
to be overweight i don't know what my
excuses i'm overweight i have three
brothers you could have any one of them
by the way if you want no i'm just
kidding i love my brothers
but but but how is it you know how can
we deal with that is
i found that only because you know we
need if we have more people on earth we
have more scientists we have more
engineers we have more committed
citizens even if they're not
scientists or engineers i despair that
because i think you know we're here on
earth we don't know why
but one of the most delightful things is
engaging the next generation of human
beings
and and having them and if we don't have
them we won't be able to engage anyway
what do you make of that trend that
seems to be in decline the birth rate
the fertility rate whatever you want to
call it
uh i i don't think you have to worry
about population if that's
if that's what you're saying if you
think there are enough people worried
about the future that they won't have
children that number is a tiny number of
people
um if you look at where the population
booms are happening
china india south america central
america
we have no worries about the world
becoming overpopulated in fact
it's overpopulation that underlies all
of this climate concern
what are they going to eat when we hit
9.7 billion people by 2050. i mean
what what are we going to feed them the
the population is growing by billions
and in many countries consumption
equals success and some of the experts i
talked to
said it's not just decarbonization of
our energies
uh network that we have to work on we
also have to work on this idea
that the purpose of being on earth is to
acquire
stuff that's another part of what's
driving
the the climate crisis is we buy more
stuff
we fly more places and so on there are
those
there are experts who say that we will
have to also
scale back our consumption driven
universe
and that's you know if there are fewer
people that means fewer people consuming
means less factories belching out
methane and carbon dioxide
less people eating beef which is oh man
if there's anything that blew my brains
out
researching this book impact of beef
that's 12 gallons of methane
per cow per hour and by the way
methane yeah nothing is 80 times worse
than carbon dioxide as a greenhouse gas
so
oh my god i have not put another quite a
dead cow in my mouth since i learned
that
um but anyway yeah so it is depressing
that there are people who are i made up
for it i make up for that david
[Laughter]
i made i made up for it sorry it is
yeah so it is a worthy concern
to worry about the next generations and
to be depressed
about the world we're leaving them
that's legitimate
but one thing you don't have to worry
about is not enough babies and not
enough future scientists
those numbers are still skyrocketing
all right david well we've reached the
uh final conclusion of the show when i
asked my uh illustrious guest to answer
the following three questions which i
call the
thrilling three impossible questions to
hear david's answer you're going to have
to subscribe to my mailing list
briankeating.com and i will send it over
to you
posthaste and uh the first one david uh
revolves around your expertise you've
done so much
for both pbs you've been a host many
many specials on pbs
uh including uh how many did you do 18
nova special science now
the elements hunting the elements uh
just so many things plus being involved
as the emcee in the national academy of
television arts
and sciences therefore i can ask you
this question
david if you're willing to play along
can you please first begin
with a 14-dimensional representation of
loop quantum gravity that is unified
with the electromagnetic and electro
weak physics theories i'll give you a
minute no i'm just kidding david
oh my god it's everything you've got to
ask that all the time
i know you're sick of that question
you're sticking that question aren't you
all right no seriously um when uh
in in in the religion of judaism the
tradition is you wish somebody to live
to 120
because that's the age moses lived until
i want to ask you
when you get to the age of 120 and
spring forth this mortal coil
what wisdom do you want to leave in what
is known in hebrew as a ethical
will a kind of a wisdom will not a
material will but a wisdom will
that you by uh biological and
ideological
errors will be uh will be air too
that's a good one that's almost as hard
as the physics question
um i think the wisdom that i would leave
is a quote from wayne gretzky
he once said you miss a hundred percent
of the shots
you don't take and that has been
the most useful piece of information in
my own life every time i
considered undertaking a project and
people said oh my god that won't work or
that's been done
or why bother you won't make money from
that whatever it is
you don't know until you do the project
whether or not it'll be a hit or not
i i left the new york times in 2013 i
used to write a weekly column
since then i'm a freelancer for them and
what that means is
when you have an idea for a story you
pitch it to the editors
and they either hire to do the story or
they say no thanks
well my hit rate is about on par with
every other freelancer
which is about two in ten ideas they
take
so you pitch them ten and two of them
they'll say yes to
you miss a hundred percent of the shots
you don't take
wow yeah and also as uh gretzky said
before he retired he said i stopped
playing
hockey because they wanted to start
paying me with a check
with a check get it david okay uh next
question
sorry dad jokes i figured i could do at
least one dad joke
um next one involves arthur c clarke's
famous film the 2001 a space odyssey by
kubrick you you've seen that i said
there's a monolith which looks a lot
like an iphone 4 when when you used to
cover that
particular there's these monoliths and
these apes come up to and they're
hitting it they're bashing it
but it's meant to be kind of like a time
capsule from an ancient
alien civilization and we can't talk
about that legally i'm forbidden by nasa
to talk about my exploits with aliens
but
i want to ask you if you had a billion
year time capsule what would you put on
it or
in it to encapsulate what humans have
learned about the natural universe or
technology it seems to me
our greatest distinction with the rest
of the animal kingdom
and our greatest distinction in the
universe as we know it
is our creativity is our art
is our ability to contemplate
consequence so
i would put in that capsule every kind
of art and science
example so not just the obvious ones
music
painting sculpture but also
our creative accomplishments in other
realms
you know architecture engineering
physics um
i think that would be what we would want
to communicate to
the the future species we weren't all
that bad
very good and the last question also
involves arthur c
clarke i'm the co-director of the arthur
c clarke center for human imagination at
uc san diego wow
and he had all these different laws one
of which is any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic and
another one is for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert but
the last one is how i got the name of
the podcast and it really relates to
advice to your former self
and the quote is the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible that's the name of
my podcast
let me ask you what about life perplexed
a 20 year old
30 year old self and by the way belated
happy birthday i think you just came up
on a birthday not too long ago
what perplexed you when you were 30
years younger than you are now
that would give a younger version of you
the courage to go
into the impossible as you so have
um i don't know if this is wise
for everybody to take but if i could
give myself advice back then
it would be the money will follow
don't do stuff just for the money do
stuff
that fulfills you you'll figure out the
money later
i i wish i had known that when i was
much younger
that's wonderful well david i want to
thank you so much for being an
inspiration to me
keeping me and my kids entertained and
my wife uh for many many years i wish
you
all the success until 120 and beyond
perhaps
uh and thank you for writing this a
particularly useful actionable
and and helpful book it really is um and
i want to just thank you so much for
the impact you've had on my life towards
the good wow well thank you man this was
obviously a huge gift to my ego
and your your kind words mean the world
and uh i'm glad writing this book wasn't
a shot i didn't take
thanks david